pour la trouver il faut partir de
l'autre côté de la terre au pôle sud
les marins qui la traquent savent qu'ils
vont devoir passer des mois à pêcher de
jour comme de nuit et par tous les temps
dans l'une des mers les plus
inhospitalières de la planète
[Musique]
ballotté par la houle malmené par des
vents glacials et des tempêtes
dévastatrices
loin bien loin de toute assistance et de
tout secours
ces nouveaux aventuriers slalome entre
les icebergs de l'antarctique pour
trouver une crevette de quelques
centimètres de long et qui pourtant vaut
de l'or
le krill
une petite crevette rose très riche en
protéines et dont certains prédisent
qu'elle permettra de nourrir l'humanité
de demain
rien de ça
cap au sud donc une équipe de thalassa
est parti sur la piste de leurs roses
dans l'océan austral ce nouvel eldorado
où se pressent des centaines d'hommes et
de femmes pour y pêcher le krill au
large de la péninsule antarctique
dans l'avion qui nous mène aux îles
falkland nous retrouvons des marins
scandinaves russes aux philippins qui
endurent le décalage horaire après deux
jours de saute-mouton d'un aéroport à
l'autre
et parmi eux qu'est jim hall est le
capitaine du sagas si l'un des deux
navires usines norvégien qu'ils vont
rejoindre au large du continent blanc
ça nous prend cinq jours pour ta port
jusqu'au bateau de pêche
c'est vrai que c'est un sacré voyage
trois heures de vol l'occasion de
plonger dans nos dossiers consacrés au
crime
cette crevette minuscule se déplaçant de
gigantesque essaim de plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres de long pour
tenter d'échapper aux oiseaux de mer aux
phoques et aux baleines qui s'en
régalent
présent dans tous les océans ce crustacé
est considérée comme l'une des espèces
les plus nombreuses sur terre sa
biomasse est estimé à 500 millions de
tonnes l'équivalent de celle de la
population humaine mais dont l'avenir
fait pourtant l'objet de bien des
inquiétudes
si les japonais le considère depuis
toujours comme un aliment de haute
gastronomie ses qualités nutritionnelles
intéresse surtout l'aquaculture mondiale
qui peine à trouver de quoi nourrir ses
poissons d'élevage
quant à son huile elle recèle des
oméga-3 et des antioxydants dont les
multiples vertus pharmaceutique ouvre
bien des espoirs
le krill est à la mode et attisent
depuis quelques années toutes les
convoitises
mais déjà les côtes de l'archipel des
falkland apparaissent dans le hublot
et l'équipage du sagas s'ils se
retrouvent bringuebalé sur la route qui
mène à la capitale port stanley les
falkland l'une des principales portes de
l'antarctique un territoire qui abrite
quelques 3000 habitants 20 fois moins
nombreux dit on que les moutons qu'ils
élèvent
pas question de traîner qu'est jim hall
et ses collègues sont attendus nettement
plus au sud et avant cela il reste
encore quelques étapes
alors capitaine on va rejoindre le saga
si non on va rejoindre la manche qui va
nous emmener jusqu'au bateau dans le
détroit devant la cheville
[Musique]
alors c'est pas encore la fin du voyage
non
comment s'appelle encore deux ou trois
jours de patience
[Musique]
la manche le navire ravitailleur qui
assure les livraisons de matériel de
carburant et d'hommes d'équipage entre
les falklands et les deux navires de
pêche de la compagnie basée en
antarctique
172 mètres de long 4 grues de
déchargement et des allures de vieux
rafiot
[Musique]
un cargo hors d'âge construit du temps
de l'urss et qui saborde à l'ancienne
par l'échelle de pilotes
[Musique]
croiser les doigts pour face à li na de
quoi nous donner quelques sueurs froides
pour notre matériel de tournage et la
suite du voyage c'est bon la cour
[Musique]
deux à trois jours de mer c'est par les
falklands de la péninsule antarctique le
territoire du krill une traversée de
l'atlantique sud le passage obligé pour
rejoindre le sag assise en espérant que
la météo locale ne nous réserve pas trop
de mauvaises surprises
à la passerelle du ravitailleur nous
rencontrons le capitaine dimitri
bogdanov originaire de vladivostok comme
tous les marins du bord
on devrait retrouver le sag assise dans
discovery bay
mais si le temps ne permet pas on devra
se rabattre rapidement sur un meilleur
endroit pour faire notre opération de
transbordement ch
il faut pas perdre de temps
[Musique]
à bord de la manche le temps passe au
rythme lancinant de la houle qui de jour
comme de nuit malmène le vieux cargo et
ses passagers
[Musique]
une attente interminable pourqué jim
hall et ses hommes qui trompent l'ennui
comme ils le peuvent tout en sachant que
c'est le prix à payer pour aller traquer
le krill au pays des glaces
s'il ya échange ya les petites nouvelles
du bord découvre pour la première fois
le navire ravitailleur et les joies du
rôle et de l'atlantique sud
je travaille comme directrice du
développement durable pour l'armateur je
vais visiter le sag assise pour mieux
comprendre les techniques de pêche mais
aussi regarder ce qui concerne l'énergie
le carburant et tous ceux qui génèrent
des émissions de co2
c'est essentiel pour moi de bien
connaître ses fonctionnements pour
essayer de les améliorer
après trois longs jours de mer les
premières terres de l'antarctique enfin
un soleil timide et claire discovery bay
et bientôt le saga s'ils se présentent à
bâbord tel un bateau fantôme rescapé
d'une de ces tempêtes dans l'atlantique
sud a le secret
ce sport
même s'il lui tarde de retrouver son
poste quelle gillot les pense surtout
aux hommes qu'il est venu remplacer
ils sont sur le bateau depuis deux mois
deux mois et demi pour certains
alors j'imagine qu'ils sont plutôt
contents de rentrer chez eux oui
les deux navires sont enfin relié à
l'abri du vent du sud et de la houle le
changement d'équipage va pouvoir
commencer
et au fait comment on va faire pour
monter à bord s'est très
avec ça jetez plutôt insolite
[Musique]
on doit monter dans cette cage ouais
exactement tout le monde et nous aussi
ouais
[Musique]
et c'est parti pour l'habituelle chassé
croisé des vacances
[Musique]
des hommes et des femmes arrivent
d'autres repartent et la relève prend
des allures de chaleureuses
retrouvailles même si chacun sait
qu'elles ne dureront que quelques
minutes
[Musique]
car bien vite le saga ci doit reprendre
la mer le krill n'attend pas
quand même tout faire rentrer là une
cabine exigu de lits superposés et un
hublot pour la vue sur mer
les dix jours que nous allons passer à
bord ne s'annonce pas vraiment comme une
croisière de luxe
un silence religieux règne à la
passerelle hook et jim hall est le
nouveau capitaine a pris les commandes
le début de campagne s'annonce bien
fastidieux le krill n'est pas au rendez
vous et le sonar du bord reste
désespérément muet
on devrait voir apparaître des nuages de
couleurs qui nous diront que le krill
est bien là mais ils bougent sans cesse
avec les courants alors c'est possible
qu'il soit un peu plus au sud qui hier
une fois qu'on va commencer à pêcher on
va se déplacer lentement alors c'est
important de trouver une zone qui vaille
vraiment locaux avant d'envoyer les
filets
[Musique]
après une longue nuit de veille les
nuages de couleurs sont enfin apparus
le krill hélas par bancs entiers qui se
dessinent sur l'écran noir des
ordinateurs du bord
le sagace y va enfin pouvoir se remplir
la panse
[Musique]
sur le pont arrière une bataille s'est
engagée pour tenter de mettre à l'eau au
plus vite les deux chalut géant du
navire
[Musique]
bon
après deux heures d'efforts les quatre
forces à des mères viennent enfin à bout
du monstre de nylon sans que personne ne
soit blessé un petit miracle
c'est sûr qu'en tout peut arriver
un câble ou des cordages jeux peuvent
rond vous voyez bien qu'il ya des objets
lourds des chaînes un peu partout des
trucs du même genre à se baladent au
dessus de nos têtes
il faut toujours être prudent
heureusement pour hampton et ses
camarades de pont le sagace y va
maintenant pouvoir pêcher pendant des
jours sans avoir à remonter le chalut
grâce à de gigantesques serpent de mer
[Musique]
on est en train de connecter ses tuyaux
au fond du filet ensuite on va y envoyer
de l'air pour créer un système
d'aspiration qui nous permettra de
pomper krill directement dans les cales
du bateau
les premières crevettes apparaissent
dans les pompes du sag assise et s'il ya
une dalle madame développement durable
nous vante l'excellence environnementale
de ce système révolutionnaire qui permet
de pêcher le krill en continu
system seller costing un engin de pasche
écologique ça permet de limiter les
pertes accidentelles comme le ferait en
remontant à châlus et en même temps on
dépense moins d'énergie donc c'est une
situation où tout le monde est gagnant
à part le krill peut-être
sept jours sur sept 24 heures sur 24 les
pompes du sagas si un gars shit jusqu'à
200 tonnes de crevettes par jour
l'aspirateur acres il permet surtout de
les récupérer fraîche et vivante sans
qu'elles aient subi la terrible
compression d'un chalut plein nous en
profitons pour en collecter une poignée
histoire de voir d'un peu plus près ces
créatures qui suscite tant d'efforts et
tant d'énergie
[Musique]
le foia superba elle porte décidément
bien son nom la petite crevette de
l'antarctique
le krill dans nos souvenirs de gosse
c'était surtout le plus petit animal du
monde qui nourrissait le plus gros la
baleine
capable de vivre à plus de 3000 mètres
de profondeur de s'abstenir de
s'alimenter pendant des mois et de
pondre jusqu'à 10000 le chaque année le
crid est en fait une super crevettes
taillé pour résister aux milieux les
plus hostiles
[Applaudissements]
perdu au milieu de nulle part
dans les coursives du sagas si nous
croisons quelques femmes et surtout des
hommes qui enchaîne quart de jour et
quart de nuit
des norvégiens aux postes clés et des
dizaines de russes qui viennent griller
un peu de leur jeunesse en antarctique
seul moyen de s'échapper les réseaux
sociaux qui permettent à anton de
communiquer régulièrement avec son fils
et sa femme helena quand je suis parti
mon fils avait quatre mois
mais quand je reviendrai il en aura neuf
ou dix peut-être
on est en contact tout le temps avec sa
mère qui lui montre des photos de moi
pour qu'il ne m'oublie pas
drôle de vie cinq mois à bord cinq mois
inter 80 heures par semaine et pas de
week-end
une vie entre parenthèses à des milliers
de kilomètres de la mère patrie mais
pour un salaire de 2500 euros par mois
une petite fortune en russie moi ça me
plaît de travailler ici la nature est
belle on travaille à l'air libre on est
pas mal payés pour faire ce travail mais
j'aimerais pas que mon fils fasse ça je
lui souhaite de pouvoir passer plus de
temps chez lui avec sa famille
j'aimerais qu'il fasse des études pour
devenir quelqu'un de bien avec un bon
salaire mais en travaillant sur la terre
ferme
[Musique]
une fumée blanche doublé d'un délicat
fumée de crevettes grillées
[Musique]
pour ce il ya il est temps de nous
emmener visiter les entrailles du sag
assise
des kilomètres de tuyaux des pompes des
cuves des fours et au début de cette
chaîne infernale le krill tout droit
sorti des eaux glacées de l'antarctique
lusine du bord tourne à plein régime
[Musique]
quel est l'intérêt de ce crime pour
l'aquaculture en utilisant 5 à 10% de
farine de krill dans l'élevage on a un
gars en protéines très important on peut
nourrir beaucoup plus de poissons
d'élevage en utilisant moins d'aliments
jugez plutôt pour produire un kilo de
saumon d'élevage il faut pêcher plus
d'un kilo et demi dans choix ou de
sardines alors que moins d'un kilo de
krill suffit pour obtenir le même
résultat
cette purée de krill riche en protéines
serait donc une solution d'avenir pour
une aquaculture mondiale de plus en plus
confrontés à l'épuisement des stocks de
poissons sauvages
cuite à haute température il ne reste
bientôt plus grand chose de la petite
crevette des glaces à part sa belle
couleur rouge brique
mais lorsque nous découvrons l'entrepôt
du sagas si c'est le choc
des dizaines des centaines de sacs de
farine de krill qui s'accumulent au
rythme des pompes et au fil de la pêche
de quoi s'inquiéter pour les baleines
non
sans voix autant de sacs on dirait que
vous allez prendre tout le crime
c'est vrai que c'est un peu trompeur
quand on voit tous ces sacs on pourrait
croire que nous prenons tout le cri de
l'antarctique
mais en fait
notre bateau comme l'ensemble de navires
qui pêchent dans cette région prennent
moins de 0 5 % de la biomasse totale de
krill de cette zone de pêche
et
sale temps sur la zone 48,1 mais la
pêche continue une tempête est annoncée
pour la nuit c'est le branle bas de
combat sur le pont arrière
on doit remonter un des deux chats lui à
cause de la météo et de ce gros temps
qui arrive ce soir
quand le temps est vraiment mauvais on
n'a pas le choix on doit accepter de
pêcher avec un seul chaliand
[Musique]
la nuit promet d'être courte pour peter
et ses hommes
[Musique]
pas question de traîner il faut rendre
le bateau un peu plus manoeuvrant avant
l'arrivée du gros temps
[Musique]
il
remonter un chalut et finalement aussi
difficile et périlleux que de le mettre
à l'eau
c'est fini tu apprennes oui c'est
terminé maintenant on est prêt pour une
nuit agitée
[Musique]
quand le vent et la neige se déchaîne
sur la péninsule antarctique
la passerelle devient un refuge
[Musique]
le saga ci n'est pas le seul à slalomer
entre les icebergs
des baleines à bosse participer au
festin et nous croisons et recroisant
régulièrement cinq autres navires usines
qui comme le nôtre traque le krill
depuis des mois
[Musique]
si l'antarctique est une zone
internationale où toute activité est
réglementée et la pêche au crime soumise
à des quotas très strictes cette
pratique affole les protecteurs de la
nature
kate gillot les accepte de nous donner
quelques explications sur les
restrictions qui lui sont imposées
les quotas sont répartis sur différentes
zones
lorsqu'ils sont atteints dans l'une
d'elle elle est fermée jusqu'à l'année
suivante
vérification faite c'est un comité
scientifique qui établit chaque année
ces quotas pour la pêche au crabe une
pêche qui depuis 1982 est autorisée
exclusivement sur quatre zones au nord
de la péninsule
48 1 48 2 3 et 4
le quota de la zone 48,1 nous sommes
actuellement est de 155 mille tonnes on
l'a bientôt atteint alors on va sans
doute devoir bouger la semaine prochaine
pour commencer à pêcher ailleurs
et pour être bien certain que cette
réglementation est respectée des
observateurs indépendants sont présents
à bord des navires de pêche
sur le saga si ces géorgiens robson qui
veille au grain
fraîchement débarqué de londres elle est
chargée de contrôler les quantités de
krill déclaré chaque soir par l'équipage
mais la mission de georgia ne s'arrête
pas là on peut même dire qu'elle a le
souci du détail
deux fois par jour elle prélève 25 kg de
krill pour les passer au peigne fin et
tenter de repérer les prises
accidentelles les plus imperceptible
c'est pas une potion des glaces un
juvénile
c'est ce genre de petit poisson qu'on
trouve dans nos échantillons et qui sont
pêchés par erreur
c'est très important car ce crime fait
partie d'un écosystème plus vaste et
c'est grâce à ce type de suivi très
précis on peut vérifier s'il y a des
conséquences négatives sur d'autres
espèces présentes dans le secteur
une pêche sous haute surveillance donc
même si des voix s'élèvent et s'inquiète
pour l'avenir d'une ressource de plus en
plus convoité
le risque dans l'avenir ce serait la
surpêche bien sûr mais c'est le cas pour
toutes les pêcheries du monde et en
attendant cette pêche est l'une des plus
suivies des plus contrôlée qui soit
pour moi c'est vraiment un excellent
exemple à suivre
en quête de krill le capitaine a décidé
de changer de zone
une petite journée de navigation et le
sagace y rejoint le secteur 48,2 où les
quotas sont encore importants
l'occasion pour georgia de découvrir les
orcades du sud des îles appartenant à
l'antarctique mais revendiquées par son
pays la grande bretagne
je suis quasiment la maison oui le temps
n'est pas très différent
il manque juste le thé et des biscuits
seul souci le crime n'est pas au rendez
vous voilà des heures que le saga six
pompes de l'eau par là que d'une
crevette à l'horizon
sur le pont arrière le chef d'equipe ne
s'explique pas la disparition du krill
d'une zone où il est d'habitude très
abondants ça n'a jamais été comme ça
avant
ça fait des années que la pêche aux cris
les bandes par ici à cette période de
l'année
mais là je sais pas ce qui se passe
ce qui est sûr c'est que la température
de l'eau est sans doute trop élevé pour
le crime on parle des effets d'el niño
ou deux trucs comme ça dans la mer c'est
peut-être une explication à tout ça
l'équipage du sagas ci n'est pas le seul
à s'inquiéter depuis quelques années les
scientifiques pointent du doigt les
effets du réchauffement climatique sur
les zones polaires et leur écosystème à
commencer par le début de la chaîne
alimentaire le krill
certains évoquent même une diminution de
sa population de 50 à 90% depuis les
années soixante dix
l'enjeu est de taille car le krill se
nourrit de micro algues et contribuer
ainsi à piéger une part importante de
co2 le principal responsable du
réchauffement climatique
sa disparition serait donc dramatique
pour l'avenir d'une planète déjà bien
menacé
installé dans l'hôpital du bord
s'il ya une dalle occupent les derniers
jours de son étrange croisière en
peaufinant son rapport sur le saga si
elle tente de nous rassurer sur l'avenir
d'une ressource dont on ne peut prélever
que 0,5 pour cent de la population
il y a quelques années on qu'on sait que
le krill donnerait lieu à une véritable
ruée vers l'or que tout le monde dirait
pêcher le krill en antarctique on s'est
rendu compte qu'il y avait quelques
étapes à franchir avant de pouvoir venir
pêcher ici et d'en faire une activité
rentable financièrement et finalement la
pêche aux crises n'a pas explosé comme
tout le monde le pensait
seulement voilà depuis quelques années
la paix chokr il connaît un nouveau
débouché à haute valeur ajoutée
je suis de retour avec comme nouveau
défi de devoir trouver le même créé que
celui qu'on trouve dans l'huile de krill
elle est naturellement bourré
d'antioxydants et d'oméga 3
faut juste que j'attends la marée haute
car derrière la carapace de ces petits
crustacés se cache une huile une huile
aux propriétés miraculeuses
bien plus assimilable par le corps
humain que ceux issus de l'huile de
poisson traditionnels les oméga-3 et les
antioxydants tiré du krill serait donc
le nouveau remède miracle contre la
pression artérielle le cholestérol ou
encore l'arthrose
[Musique]
la majorité de la population mondiale
montre des carence en oméga 3 et à
condition bien sûr qu'on puisse
exploiter le krill sans impact sur
l'écosystème c'est une solution très
prometteuse pour le futur
décidément les propriétés du krill
semble intéresser de plus en plus de
monde
après deux semaines de pêche les cales
du sagas si son plein à craquer il est
temps pour l'équipage de retrouver la
manche le navire ravitailleur
[Musique]
des centaines et des centaines de sacs
passe bientôt d'une cale à l'autre 1600
tonnes de farine de krill transbordée
pendant des heures
et nous nous interrogeons
cette pêche va-t-elle suivre le destin
tragique de celle de la morue de
terre-neuve et de la chasse baleinière
en atlantique nord où l'humanité va
t-elle se montrer capable de préserver
une ressource essentielle à l' équilibre
de notre climat
[Musique]